[Music]
it's been estimated that 90% of many of
the large pelagic sharks have been
fished out of the oceans in the last 50
years 10% left within 50 years we're
just too good at fishing and now we've
got this practice that's actually
targeting sharks it's a real real ocean
crisis sharks have shaped evolution in
the ocean the fact that fish are
camouflage their speed their behavior
has all been influenced by the shark
so you remove the shark and then you can
cause some serious problems with
diversity in the in the oceans shark
finning is the process where a shark is
caught it's brought aboard quite often
it's clubbed or stabbed to avoid harm to
the fisherman and the fins are cut off
and the animal is thrown back over the
side alive
the shark fins are very valuable they're
the most valuable dried seafood product
per weight one fin can cost hundreds of
dollars it's highly prized in Asian
cuisine for shark fin soup and this was
a ceremonial dish at one time hundreds
of years ago unfortunately it's become
extremely popular in banquets and
business luncheons so where once there
was just a few people eating shark fins
now there are literally millions of
people eating shark fin and it's
decimating species literally around the
world ocean
sharks are extremely vulnerable to
overfishing because they have very late
onset reproductions sometimes 15
sometimes 20 years for some of the
larger sharks they're much like humans
in that respect they also have few young
so if you're killing a shark you're you
may be killing a shark that's never had
a chance to reproduce or you may be
killing a shark that can only have maybe
25 or 30 children if you will or pups in
its entire lifetime it's not like a fish
that can have millions of eggs that can
broadcast millions of eggs out there and
have a high percentage of success you
kill a great white shark and you can
knock out a generation in a local
population
the Sharks are going to be gone in
decades not hundreds of years are going
to be gone in a decade or two they're
just going to be gone it's already
happening in places where there are
specific shark species that you don't
see anymore in certain parts of the
world at all they're never sighted
anymore and it's not because they've
decided to give somewhere else it's
because there simply aren't any left
because if you can get $12 for a fin
u.s. dollars for a thin in a place where
you might make nine dollars a month in
wages you'll kill as many sharks as you
possibly can in a month to make a
hundred times what your normal income
would be and that's the profit motive
that's the incentive cuz that's why in
places like Galapagos they'll kill a
million sharks in a year in one island
chain they'll kill a million sharks in a
million fins at $12 apiece sharks mean a
healthy ocean if we're taking sharks out
we're taking the regulator out we're
taking the animals that are really
keeping things clean that are really
keeping animals strong and it's not only
the sharks that are going it's the big
fish really they're shooting themselves
in their own foot so by killing that
apex predator they change the whole
pyramid and the fish will go somewhere
else the same thing that happened in
Southern California you kill all the
sheephead that eat the urchins and then
the urchins explode they eat the kelp
and then the kelp goes away and then all
the species on the west coast of the
United States have disappeared
nikhyl because they all dependant on
living in the kill so it one thing
always affects something else you can go
down to San Francisco Chinatown right
now and walk into any number of
restaurants and order a bowl of shark
fin soup it's not illegal it it's
commonly served it's everywhere it's
really not a cultural thing we can
change our cultural practices if they're
not sustainable
the Chinese binding feat that was that
was a cultural practice that's not
really observed anymore and it's not
really looked favorably upon so we can't
change what we consider our cultural
values into what our sustainable values
the shark fin trade is like a black
market it's like drugs it's small it's
easily transported it's easily smuggled
and it's destroying our world ocean it's
killing the regulators of the oceans
[Music]
Hawaii just signed a bill that's going
into law to ban shark fins landing in
the whole state of Hawaii
this is landmark legislation and they're
including in that is banning shark fin
products which means shark fin soup I
founded a nonprofit called sea stewards
and we're trying to do the same thing in
San Francisco unfortunately people
historically only begin to care when it
starts to impact their lives when they
start to feel it when they start to
suffer we respond to tragedies we
respond to crises and disasters but we
have this very little of no ability to
look forward into the future and look at
consequences really some of the most
important animals in the ocean are
sharks and they're being killed for fins
[Music]